una carrera desesperada para llenar los
tanques de gasolina mientras en si la
ncaa escasea combustible los conductores
no son los únicos que se están quedando
sin dice la disminución de los
suministros de hidrocarburos está
afectando también a la red eléctrica del
país provocando apagones que duran horas
mientras que los supermercados se han
visto obligados a racionar algunos
productos
no es sólo combustible la gente no tiene
suficiente para comer cualquier
combustible que consigamos cuánto tiempo
durará andar en dvd la crisis del
combustible en sí blanca responde a la
escasez en las reservas de divisas con
el turismo golpeado por la pandemia y
las remesas de los trabajadores en el
extranjero en un continuo descenso las
reservas en dólares del país se situaban
en enero en algo menos de 24 mil
millones esto cuando el país se enfrenta
a unos 7.000 millones de dólares en
obligaciones de deuda externa sólo para
2022 el ministerio de energía afirma que
ya no puede conseguir préstamos
comerciales mientras que la escasez de
combustible en la red eléctrica se ve
agravada por el bajo nivel de agua en
las represas hidroeléctricas
estamos siendo golpeados por dos lados
por uno está la falta de energía
hidroeléctrica y por el otro la subida
de los el petróleo en el mercado mundial
por estas dos razones el sector del
petróleo y el de la electricidad están
sometidos a una enorme presión mientras
tanto la inflación lleva cuatro meses
consecutivos alcanzando máximos
históricos en enero los precios al
consumo subieron casi un 17% respecto al
año anterior los esfuerzos por
restablecer las finanzas del país han
sido infructuosos hasta ahora una nueva
propuesta de impuestos fue rechazada por
el tribunal supremo- mientras que el
gobierno es incapaz de ponerse de
acuerdo para solicitar un rescate al
fondo monetario internacional